>>> TURNING NOW TO NEW YORK,
STARTING TODAY A NEW STATE LAW
ALLOWS ADULT SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
ABUSE TO SUE THEIR ALLEGED
ABUSERS REGARDLESS OF WHEN THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS EXPIRES.
A FLOOD OF LAWSUITS IS NOW
EXPECTED AND ONE OF THE FIRST
ONES WAS BROUGHT AGAINST FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
LET'S BRING IN CNN KARA
SCANNELL.
IT WAS BROUGHT BY E. JEAN
CARROLL, THE SECOND TIME SHE'S
TRIED TO SUE HIM.
HOW IS THIS DIFFERENT FROM THE
FIRST ONE?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, BORIS.
HAPPY THANKSGIVING TO YOU.
THE FIRST LAWSUIT WAS BROUGHT IN
2019 THEN E. JEAN CARROLL SUED
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
FOR DEFAMATION WHEN SHE SAID HE
DEFAMED HER WHEN SHE DENIED HER
ALLEGATIONS HE RAPED HER IN A
DRESSING ROOM OF A NEW YORK
DEPARTMENT STORE.
AT THE TIME TRUMP SAID HE DIDN'T
KNOW HER.
SHE WASN'T HIS TYPE AND MADE
THAT UP TO BOOST SALES OF HER
BOOK BUT TODAY SHE IS SUING HIM
UNDER THAT NEW LAW SUING HIM FOR
BATTERY AND DEFAMATION.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME SHE IS
SUING HIM FOR THE ACTUAL
ALLEGATIONS OF ASSAULT AND SHE'S
ALSO SUING HIM FOR A NEW CLAIM
OF DEFAMATION, ONE IN A
STATEMENT THAT HE MADE JUST LAST
MONTH.
NOW, THIS LAWSUIT CAME UNDER THE
ADULT SURVIVOR'S ACT.
THE WINDOW, A ONE-YEAR WINDOW
FOR ANYONE WHO BELIEVES THEY
WERE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED AND
WANTS TO SEEK REMEDY.
THAT WINDOW OPENS TODAY.
E. JEAN CARROLL AMONG ONE OF THE
FIRST TO BE MANY LAWSUITS
BROUGHT UNDER THAT AND THERE
WILL BE ONE YEAR FOR ANY VICTIMS
TO MAKE THESE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST ANY OF THEIR ALLEGED
ATTACKERS, BORIS.
>> YEAH, AND, THAT FIRST
LAWSUIT, IT COULD BE DECIDED IN
THE COMING MONTHS.
DO YOU KNOW IF THAT WILL HAVE
ANY OUTCOME ON THIS NEW YORK
LAWSUIT, ANY BEARING ON THAT?
>> IT REALLY SHOULDN'T BECAUSE
THAT FIRST LAWSUIT IS NOW UP
BEFORE A D.C. APPEALS COURT AND
THE ISSUE THERE IS WHETHER THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WAS ACTING
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF HIS DUTIES
WHEN HE MADE THESE STATEMENTS
DENYING THE ATTACK AND THE
STATEMENTS THAT CARROLL SAYS
WERE DEFAMATORY.
IF THE D.C. COURT RULES IN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S FAVOR THAT
WILL LIKELY GET THROWN OUT BUT
NEW CLAIMS ABOUT ASSAULT AS WELL
AS THE DEFAMATION LAWSUIT, THIS
DEFAMATION STATEMENT TRUMP MADE
LAST MONTH WHEN HE WAS CLEARLY
NOT IN OFFICE, NO LONGER
PRESIDENT SO HE WON'T BE ABLE TO
USE THE SAME LEGAL ARGUMENTS
HERE.
THEY'RE BOTH PLAYING OUT
SIMULTANEOUS.
CARROLL'S LAWYERS ARE HOPEFUL
AND THEY WANT THE JUDGE TO
COMBINE THEM AND GO TO TRIAL
EARLY NEXT YEAR.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH AND HAPPY
THANKSGIVING.
ANOTHER TOPIC HERE, THE FORMER
MAGAZINE COLUMNIST.
E. JEAN CARROLL IS SUING TRUMP
FOR BATTERY, IT ALLOWS ADULTS
ALLEGING SEXUAL ASSAULT.
IN 2019 SHE SUED HIM FOR
DEFAMATION, NOT BAYRY.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THIS CASE
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW?
DOES SHE HAVE A CASE HERE AND
ARE WE LIKELY TO SEE RESOLUTION
SOON?
>> IT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT UNDER
THE NEW LAW.
SHE WAS NOT -- SHE CLAIMS, BY
THE WAY, IN THE 1990s SHE WAS
RAPED AND GROPED BY TRUMP IN AN
ELEVATOR AT BERGDORF GOODMAN,
ONE OF THE MOST PRESTIGIOUS
DEPARTMENT STORES IN NEW YORK.
SHE NEVER BROUGHT A CASE WITHIN
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
HOWEVER, WHEN TRUMP BECAME
PRESIDENT, HE ANSWERED A
REPORTER'S QUESTION ABOUT E.
JEAN CARROLL'S CLAIMS.
SOME CLEVER LAWYERS LOOKED AT IT
AND SAID, YOU KNOW SOMETHING,
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS IS
STILL ALIVE ON DEFAMATION.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING UP THE
WHOLE RAPE CASE BY CLAIMING IT'S
A DEFAMATION CASE.
THAT CASE HAS BEEN GOING ON IN
THE COURTS FOR A LONG TIME NOW.
WHAT SHE'S DOING NOW WITH THIS
NEW LAW THAT ALLOWS ANYBODY --
ELIMINATES THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS IN CIVIL CLAIMS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT IS TO COMBINE THE
TWO CASES.
I THINK THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE
THE JUDGE WILL GO ALONG WITH
COMBINING THEM ALL, AND SHE MAY
HAVE A CLAIM THAT SHE AT LEAST
CAN ASSERT AND TRY TO PROVE IN
COURT.
TOUGH CASE TO PROVE, JIM.
IT'S ANCIENT.
IT'S A ONE-ON-ONE SITUATION
OBVIOUSLY AND A PRETTY STRANGE
FACT PATTERN, SAYING IT OCCURRED
IN A DRESSING ROOM AT BERGDORF
GOODMAN.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH IT.
>> A CASE WHERE THE PRESIDENT'S
WORDS MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN HIM IN
TROUBLE AND AT LEAST OPENED THIS
CASE FOR ADD JUTD CASE YET
AGAIN.
PAUL CALLAN, THANKS SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU, JIM.